(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre o laudo
de avaliação.
Nos processos judiciais, quando um juiz determina que
algum imóvel vá a leilão para quitar a
dívida de alguém, será necessário encontrar o valor
desse imóvel.
A regra é que, para encontrar o valor
desse imóvel, vai ser necessário elaborar um laudo
de avaliação.
Então, nem o juiz, nem nenhuma das partes,
nem a parte que está executando a dívida,
nem a parte que está sendo executada por
aquela dívida, vai falar qual é o valor
do imóvel.
A regra é que tem a elaboração de
um laudo de avaliação.
Existe uma exceção quando as duas partes concordam
sobre o valor do imóvel.
Então, se as duas partes concordarem com o
valor do imóvel e forem apresentados anúncios de
imóveis similares pelo mesmo preço, pode ser que
o juiz determine que seja utilizado esse valor
que as partes chegaram a um consenso.
Mas isso é exceção.
A regra é a elaboração do laudo de
avaliação.
O Código de Processo Civil, que é a
lei que traz todas as regras dos leilões
judiciais, vai falar que esse laudo de avaliação
deve ser feito por um oficial de justiça,
exceto se o valor da execução comporte uma
avaliação técnica.
E aqui é importante registrar que como um
imóvel tem um valor elevado, na maioria das
vezes, os juízes preferem determinar que seja feita
essa avaliação técnica.
Essa avaliação técnica, então, vai ser realizada geralmente
por engenheiros ou arquitetos cadastrados naquele tribunal que
está determinando o leilão.
Então, o juiz vai escolher um arquiteto, um
engenheiro ou algum outro profissional habilitado para fazer
essa função, ou seja, elaborar um laudo de
avaliação de um imóvel e vai determinar que
esse perito realize um laudo de avaliação.
O laudo de avaliação é muito importante para
quem está interessado em arrematar um imóvel em
leilão judicial.
Por quê?
Porque esse laudo pode trazer muitas informações importantes
para quem está interessado em participar daquele leilão.
O laudo de avaliação, se ele for elaborado
por um perito, ele é muito mais completo.
Ele vai trazer informações de como é a
região daquele imóvel, se aquele imóvel for situado
dentro de um condomínio, vai trazer informações do
condomínio.
Por exemplo, se for um prédio, vai trazer
informações de quantos andares tem um prédio, quantos
apartamentos por andar tem aquele prédio, o que
tem de lazer naquele prédio, se aquele prédio
tem piscinas, se ele tem academia, se tem
alguma outra estrutura de lazer.
Vai trazer informações completas do imóvel que está
sendo colocado em leilão, como é a disposição
daquele imóvel, quantos metros quadrados tem aquele imóvel,
se aquele imóvel tem dois, três, quatro quartos,
quantos ambientes existem na sala daquele imóvel, como
é que é a cozinha, se existe ou
não dependência de serviço naquele imóvel.
Enfim, o laudo de avaliação, ele traz todas
as informações do imóvel.
E aí existe uma diferença entre um laudo
de avaliação realizado por um oficial de justiça
e um laudo de avaliação realizado por um
perito, que na maioria das vezes é um
engenheiro ou um arquiteto.
Por quê?
Porque o laudo de avaliação elaborado por um
oficial de justiça, ele vai ser muito mais
simples Geralmente esse laudo possui somente uma página,
vai conter a descrição do imóvel e aí
o oficial de justiça vai usar a mesma
descrição do imóvel que tem na matrícula do
imóvel, então vai constar a área que tem
na matrícula do imóvel, se tem ou não
vaga de garagem, tudo de acordo com a
matrícula do imóvel.
E o oficial ele vai indicar um valor
para aquele imóvel, aí você pode se perguntar,
mas o oficial de justiça não é um
profissional mais qualificado para indicar o valor de
um imóvel, afinal de contas ele não trabalha
com imóvel, como é que ele pode saber
o valor?
Esse oficial de justiça vai fazer um levantamento
com corretores de imóveis daquela região, então ele
vai consultar corretores de imóveis que trabalham naquela
região e vai falar que tem um imóvel
com tal característica, qual é o preço médio
daquele imóvel com tal característica Já os laudos
elaborados por peritos, eles são muito mais completos
eles vão trazer todas as informações que eu
falei anteriormente e podem até apresentar fotos internas
do condomínio e até do imóvel que está
sendo levado a leilão.
Aqui cabe uma observação, quando o perito vai
fazer uma avaliação, pode ser que ele tenha
acesso ou não ao interior daquele imóvel que
está indo a leilão, se ele não tiver
acesso ao interior daquele imóvel que está indo
a leilão, se por exemplo for um apartamento
pode ser que ele tenha acesso a um
chamado imóvel paradigma, o que é esse imóvel
paradigma?
É um imóvel que vai ter características muito
parecidas com aquele imóvel que está indo a
leilão, mas como o perito não teve acesso
ao imóvel do leilão especificamente, ele pode ter
acesso a esse imóvel paradigma e registrar fotos
internas de como é esse imóvel paradigma isso
também já traz muita noção para quem está
interessado em arrematar porque por mais que você
não veja aquele imóvel especificamente que você está
analisando você pode ver um muito parecido com
ele, e você pode até com esse muito
parecido com ele tirar uma estimativa de como
deve estar o estado de conservação do imóvel
que você está analisando.
Por quê?
Porque você pode analisar a idade daquele imóvel,
se for um imóvel mais novo, dificilmente esse
imóvel vai ter problemas mais graves, pode ser
que ele tenha que apresentar somente um reparo
na estética do imóvel, ou seja, uma pintura
nas paredes, consertar alguma parte do piso que
esteja danificada, coisas assim.
Já se ele for um imóvel mais antigo
pode ser que esse imóvel mais antigo precise
de uma obra mais completa em relação ao
imóvel mais novo, então quando você tem acesso
a fotos de um imóvel similar ao que
você está analisando, isso já pode te ajudar
muito também é válido sempre consultar sites especializados
em anúncios de venda para ver se você
encontra algum outro imóvel similar ao que você
está analisando ou até mesmo você pode encontrar
o imóvel que você está analisando isso não
é raro de acontecer.
Existem proprietários que quando eles sabem que eles
vão perder o apartamento, eles tentam vender o
apartamento por fora para fazer uma proposta e
acabar com aquele processo judicial que existe então
ele tenta conseguir um comprador para o seu
imóvel, e caso ele consiga ele vai explicar
para aquele comprador que ele está com uma
restrição judicial mas que ele precisa de um
dinheiro para resolver, então ele pode combinar um
valor de uma entrada e já que está
o que ele está devendo na justiça e
com esse valor ele pagaria quem ele deve
e liberaria o imóvel dele de leilão então
é normal você conseguir até anúncios do próprio
imóvel que você está analisando, e esses anúncios
na maioria das vezes possuem fotos internas do
apartamento.
Agora não se preocupe se você está analisando
um imóvel que está a leilão e você
encontrar anúncio de venda daquele imóvel em leilão,
pode ter certeza que aquele imóvel não vai
ser vendido sem uma autorização judicial porque na
matrícula daquele imóvel vai constar penhora, mas a
frente aqui no módulo 3 nós vamos estudar
o que é penhora, e quando consta uma
penhora o cartório de registro de imóvel é
proibido de registrar algum contrato de compra e
venda, então não existe a possibilidade desse proprietário
vender o imóvel sem a concordância do juiz
que determinou aquela penhora, então você não precisa
ficar preocupado de você comprar um imóvel em
leilão e esse imóvel também estar sendo vendido
de maneira tradicional essa venda tradicional não vai
acontecer sem a autorização de um juiz.
Eu separei aqui para a gente entender dois
laudos de avaliação, um feito por um oficial
de justiça e o outro feito por um
perito, vamos começar aqui pelo oficial de justiça,
veja esse laudo ele tem apenas uma página,
foi um laudo determinado pelo Tribunal de Justiça
do Estado de São Paulo, consta o número
do processo esse aqui é o número do
processo e as informações que o oficial achou
relevante, ele compareceu no dia 9 de outubro
de 2019 em determinado endereço cumprindo determinada ordem
de um juiz essas informações que ele vai
colocar aqui são basicamente as informações que constam
na matrícula, que é o endereço, a área
total, a área privativa, se tem ou não
vaga de garagem e por fim ele bota
o valor de avaliação, 120 mil reais, como
eu falei anteriormente esse laudo realizado por um
oficial de justiça, ele não passa grandes informações
nem de um condomínio, no caso desse imóvel
que especificamente está dentro de um condomínio nem
do imóvel, ele faz uma avaliação básica, coloca
basicamente os dados que a gente encontra na
matrícula e dá o valor da avaliação, agora
vamos analisar aqui um laudo feito por um
perito, veja esse perito é um engenheiro civil
e esse laudo ele tem 48 páginas então
esse laudo é muito completo, esse laudo ele
vai trazer várias informações como exemplo que eu
falei que alguns laudos tem fotos internas eu
vou passar aqui para a página 10 desse
laudo para a gente ver, veja que o
perito ele colocou fotos internas do condomínio, salão
de jogos playground, piscina e aí ele começa
a colocar fotos internas da unidade, essa unidade
é a unidade 43 que está sendo a
leilão, então veja tem uma varanda, tem um
lavabo tem as fotos da sala e aqui
a gente consegue ter muita noção de qual
é o estado desse imóvel esse imóvel além
de estar vazio, ele está todo reformado o
piso dele está reformado, a parede está pintada,
é um imóvel com um piso moderno, afinal
porcelanato é o que as pessoas preferem hoje
em dia e continua trazendo mais fotos, traz
fotos do quarto fotos do banheiro, você pode
ver como o banheiro está todo reformado então
esse imóvel ele traz informações muito mais completas,
com esse laudo aqui você pode participar de
um leilão, até mesmo sabendo que você não
vai precisar naquele imóvel gastar nenhum valor para
restaurar aquele imóvel esse imóvel aqui provavelmente ele
não precisa nem de uma pintura, ele está
pintado e ele está reformado mas então você
deve deixar de arrematar um imóvel se o
laudo de avaliação não trouxer fotos especificamente do
imóvel que está sendo leiloado?
Não, faça as análises que a gente já
falou no módulo 1, entre em contato se
for um imóvel dentro de um condomínio com
a portaria desse condomínio, peça informações, zelador, porteiros
síndicos, são fontes de informações muito valiosas para
quem quer arrematar um imóvel, podem te passar
informações concretas sobre o estado de conservação daquele
imóvel, se aquele imóvel passou ou não por
uma reforma quantos anos tem aquele condomínio, se
é um condomínio mais velho ou um condomínio
mais novo, qual é a área de lazer
daquele condomínio, realmente se o imóvel for uma
casa de rua, por exemplo, vai ficar mais
difícil de você ter essas informações se o
laudo não trouxer, mas se você não tiver
informação alguma sobre o estado de conservação daquele
imóvel, já coloque na sua calculadora daquele leilão,
algum valor estimado de obra faça um levantamento
em sites que existem de material de construção
veja um piso que você considera ok e
faça o orçamento da metragem que seria necessária
daquele piso, porque pelo menos a área interna
daquele imóvel você vai ter, até olhando a
matrícula, a matrícula vai falar qual é a
área privativa daquele imóvel, a área privativa é
a real área interna daquele imóvel, como a
gente já falou anteriormente, então faça essa análise
e veja, porque pode ser que esse imóvel
vá a um leilão judicial com desconto muito
grande em comparação com o valor de mercado
algo que compense até mesmo que você faça
uma obra naquele imóvel e depois revenda aquele
imóvel, então isso é perfeitamente válido, agora cabe
a você como interessado em relatar determinado imóvel,
fazer esse levantamento se o laudo de avaliação
não te oferecer esses elementos, agora se o
laudo de avaliação for como esse laudo que
eu mostrei aqui em segundo lugar de um
perito que traz informações internas, você pode arrematar
absolutamente sem medo que aquele imóvel não precisa
de qualquer reparo, aquele imóvel você vai arrematar
e se o seu interesse for investimento e
você vai colocar a venda, e se o
seu interesse for moradia, você também pode fazer
uma arrematação segura de que você vai arrematar
aquele imóvel e após a desocupação aquele imóvel
vai estar pronto para você entrar e morar
você não vai precisar reformar um banheiro, você
não vai precisar trocar um piso porque o
imóvel já está todo reformado.
Qual é a importância que existe no laudo
de avaliação encontrar o valor do imóvel?
O leilão judicial, como a gente já falou
no módulo 1 ele pode ter duas praças,
a primeira e a segunda praça o imóvel
ele vai em primeira praça exatamente pelo valor
do laudo de avaliação por isso que o
laudo de avaliação é um elemento muito importante
no leilão judicial porque é esse laudo de
avaliação que vai falar qual é o valor
mínimo para que o imóvel seja vendido em
primeira praça, e em segunda praça vai cedir
um desconto determinado pelo juiz, a gente vai
estudar um pouco mais a frente aqui nesse
módulo que o desconto máximo que o juiz
pode conceder em um leilão judicial é 50
% do valor da avaliação, então em primeira
praça pelo valor da avaliação, em segunda praça
pelo valor de desconto concedido pelo juiz, que
pode chegar em até 50% do valor
do laudo de avaliação, essa é a grande
importância do laudo de avaliação, e além de
ter essa importância para definir o preço, o
laudo de avaliação pode ser uma grande fonte
de informação para quem está interessado em rematar
aquele imóvel porque pode ser que você tenha
dados reais de qual é o estado de
conservação daquele imóvel.
Uma observação muito importante para a gente finalizar
essa aula, pode ser que entre a data
da elaboração do laudo de avaliação até a
data efetiva do leilão passem muitos anos, e
isso pode ter vários motivos, um exemplo muito
comum é, foi elaborado o laudo de avaliação,
o juiz está quase determinando que aquele imóvel
vá a leilão, e aí o executado e
o exequente fazem um acordo para tentar por
fim aquela dívida sem que seja necessário realizar
um leilão, pode ser que esse acordo contém
a previsão de que o valor vai ser
pago em alguns meses, vamos supor aqui 20
meses, então as partes, o exequente e o
executado, vão levar aquele acordo que eles fizeram
para o juiz, para o juiz homologar aquele
acordo e suspender o processo, enquanto aquele acordo
deve ser cumprido, então no nosso caso a
gente falou de um acordo em 20 meses,
o juiz vai receber aquele acordo e vai
suspender aquele processo, então vamos supor que o
executado ele pagou 18 meses daquele acordo, faltando
2 meses, quando faltavam 2 meses, ele parou
de pagar aquele acordo, o exequente então vai
retomar aquele processo judicial que já existia, pedindo
que o juiz determine que o imóvel vá
a leilão, porque o executado descumpriu o acordo
que eles tinham para o pagamento daquela dívida,
o juiz quando isso acontece ele não vai
determinar que outro laudo de avaliação seja elaborado,
porque o laudo de avaliação ele tem um
custo, o laudo de avaliação de um perito
judicial, por exemplo, ele custa em média de
R$4.500 a R$6.000 então
isso é um custo bem alto para o
exequente pagar e depois cobrar do executado, então
o que o juiz faz?
Ele vai mandar que aquele laudo de avaliação
que já existe naquele processo, passe pela atualização
daquele valor, e esse valor do laudo de
avaliação que já existia, então vai ser atualizado
muitas vezes pela tabela do próprio tribunal, só
para explicar aqui, os tribunais eles costumam ter
tabelas próprias de correção monetária, mas além das
tabelas de correção monetária, também existem outras formas
de correção, outras taxas que podem ser aplicadas
para a correção como a taxa vinculada à
inflação, como a taxa Selic taxa IGPM, mas
os tribunais eles geralmente tem sua própria tabela
de atualização dos valores, então o juiz vai
determinar que aquele laudo de avaliação passe por
essa atualização monetária, no nosso caso aqui, o
processo ficou suspenso por um ano e meio,
e até a retomada do processo e a
efetiva realização do leilão, ainda vão passar mais
alguns meses então veja bem, aquele laudo de
avaliação vai passar por um valor de correção
monetária, mas pode ser que o valor de
mercado daquele bem tenha atualizado muito mais do
que o simples correção monetária daquele valor, isso
é bem comum, é bem comum que a
gente pegue casos de leilão judicial ou de
um laudo de avaliação foi elaborado 3, 4
anos antes da realização do leilão, e aquele
valor do laudo de avaliação então, só vai
passar pela correção monetária mas na prática, no
valor de mercado, aquele imóvel ele teve um
crescimento de valor muito superior a esse valor
de correção monetária, então existem alguns casos e
que pode ser interessante arrematar um imóvel até
mesmo em primeira praça, a maioria desses casos
que é interessante arrematar um imóvel até mesmo
em primeira praça, é exatamente esse que eu
acabei de explicar, quando o laudo de avaliação
foi elaborado bem antes da realização do leilão,
seja por qual motivo for, o juiz vai
determinar que aquele laudo ele passa por uma
correção monetária, e pode ser que o valor
de mercado tenha crescido muito mais que o
valor daquela simples correção monetária, o que pode
ser interessante que você arremate esse imóvel até
em primeira praça, fique atento sempre a isso,
porque tem muita gente que já descarta de
cara a primeira praça, fala vou esperar esse
imóvel passar para a segunda praça, e aquele
imóvel pode não passar para a segunda praça
porque pode ser que alguém fique atento que
o valor da primeira praça já está muito
abaixo do valor de mercado, e já é
interessante arrematar de cara na primeira praça faça
sempre essa análise para saber se é ou
não vantajoso arrematar em primeira praça, algo que
você deve saber ao analisar um laudo de
avaliação, é que esse laudo de avaliação ele
pode ter o valor igual ao valor de
mercado inferior ao valor de mercado, ou superior
ao valor de mercado como é que você
vai saber disso, qual é o caso específico
daquele imóvel que você está analisando, você deve
recorrer aquilo que a gente já falou diversas
vezes aqui no curso, você deve recorrer a
sites especializados em vendas de anúncios de imóveis
na internet, e também a corretores de imóveis
daquela localidade, então verifique se o valor do
laudo de avaliação, ou seja, se o valor
que o imóvel será levado em primeira praça
está ou não parecido com o valor de
mercado, isso é muito importante para você analisar
a viabilidade econômica de você participar ou não
daquele leilão, é importante que você saiba então
se o valor de mercado está próximo ao
valor do laudo de avaliação que foi encontrado,
só assim você poderá calcular o valor máximo
de lance que você pode oferecer naquele imóvel
usando sua calculadora do leilão que foi disponibilizada
no módulo 1.